[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur france 24 55e
jours de guerre en ukraine les russes
sont passés à l'offensive dans le
donbass ils concentrent leurs efforts
sur la quasi totalité de la ligne de
front dans les régions de donetsk
lougansk ou encore kharkiv moscou a mené
des dizaines de frappes aériennes la
nuit dernière pour libérer l'est de
l'ukraine selon le ministre russe de la
défense selon le pentagone la russie a
augmenté de 11 bataillon une semaine sa
présence militaire dans l'est et le sud
de l'ukraine moscou dispose ainsi de 76
bataillon c'est une nouvelle phase de la
guerre qui est en cours selon l'armée
ukrainienne joe biden a organisé une
réunion virtuelle aujourd'hui avec ses
principaux alliés réunion à laquelle a
participé emmanuel macron le président
américain a évoqué le soutien continu à
l'ukraine alors poutine peut-il obtenir
une victoire sur le dombass avant le 9
mai date anniversaire de la grande
guerre patriotique que signifie le
dombass pour le chef du kremlin où en
est la résistance ukrainienne le dombass
nouvelle phase de la guerre en ukraine
on en discute avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés anastasia
sapochnik car chapeau china pardon
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue dans le
débat présidente du think tank eastern
circle est maître de conférences en
géopolitique à sciences po spécialiste
des relations europe russie en face de
vous domique trinquant bonsoir ancien
chef de la mission militaire française
auprès de l'onu bienvenue à vous
également nous avons par skype de kiev
tetyana regard kova bonsoir journaliste
responsable du département international
à l'ukraine kreis media center bienvenue
à vous
et puis nous avons notre correspondant à
kiev du l'hiver craag correspondant donc
pour france24 bonsoir gulliver
c'est l'enfer c'était mieux hier soir
sur facebook lé gouverneur ukrainien de
la région de lougansk que sir guy gedda
les combats sont incessants dans
plusieurs villes avant d'en discuter je
vous propose un récit en images de kevin
batista
hinwil prise entre deux feux à robijns
et dans l'est de l'ukraine ses habitants
on veut l'armée ukrainienne se retirer
ils subissent les bombardements des deux
camps depuis plusieurs jours
ce n'est pas clair nous ne savons même
pas d'où ça vient nous attendions à ce
que les tirs arrive de là en pensant que
l'armée ukrainienne ou sauverait mais là
c'est arrivé par là bas il est des tirs
d'obus qui viennent de tous les côtés
surtout le front est les forces russes
intensifient leurs opérations d'après
qu'est un tram à tort ce que la plupart
des civils ont déjà fui ceux qui restent
affichent leur détachement face à l'
approche des russes
je le prends calmement ce qui doit
arriver arrivera
je ne vais pas m'enfuir n'importe où
cette ville comme celle de ce lot viande
sont des objectifs de l'armée russe
après quatre semaines de guerre elle a
annoncé se concentrer sur l'est de
l'ukraine tirs d'artillerie frappes de
missiles bombardements aériens le
ministère russe de la défense égrène ses
succès dans la région
l'aviation des forces aériennes russes a
touché 60 installations militaires de
l'ukraine
deux entrepôts de missiles ont été
détruits près des villes de czerny à
poliana et la clé
plutôt discret sur ses opérations
jusqu'ici l'état major russe diffuse ces
images elles montreraient des tirs de
missiles iskander sur des installations
militaires du crédit
au sud du dombass la ville de marioupol
résiste toujours l'armée russe qu'ils
encerclent depuis plus d'un mois et demi
a lancé un ultimatum au dernier
défenseur ukrainien un appel rejeté par
les soldats qui se disent prêts à
combattre jusqu'au bout
on écoute au titre le ministre russe de
la défense haggaï faugoo et le président
ukrainien volodimir et l'inscrit
l'armée russe exécutent les tâches
fixées par le chef des armées pour
l'opération militaire spéciale en
conséquence le plan de libération des
républiques populaires de thoniers à
kehl où on skie mise en oeuvre ainsi que
des mesures pour restaurer la paix
nous pouvons maintenant confirmé que les
troupes russes ont commencé la bataille
pour le donbass qu'elle prépare depuis
longtemps
une grande partie de l'armée russe est
désormais dédié à cette offensive la
thur peu importe le nombre de soldats
russes à mener ici nous nous battrons
nous nous défendrons demain nous le
ferons quotidiennement
2013 quand est ce que c'est vraiment une
nouvelle phase de la guerre oui c'est
une phase mais qui était annoncé
après avoir pendant quatre semaines eu
plusieurs vagues d'attac comprenant kiev
kharkiv est
et des échecs en fait l'armée russe
s'est concentré sur le dôme basse ce qui
stratégiquement se comprend on renforce
le succès on concentre les efforts on
met une unité du commandement le général
qui a été nommé pour commander donc tout
ceci est parfaitement logique
la question qui se pose c'est les russes
dispose-t-il des moyens pour enfoncer la
défense ukrainienne où la contourner et
la contourner d'ailleurs et c'est là que
ça la question fondamentale les rues
sont il a ajouté des milliers de soldats
comme l'affirment le pentagone il y aura
un total de 76 bataillon qu'est ce que
ça signifie alors c'est difficile à dire
combien ce que ça veut dire parce que
lorsqu'on voit que des bataillons ou des
brigades même avait été annoncée à 100 %
est en fête et à 50 % de leurs effectifs
on s'aperçoit que ça veut pas dire grand
chose
deuxième point ces batailles en haussant
deal de nouveaux bataillons ou des
bataillons qui viennent de biélorussie
des bataillons qui viennent de la région
de kiev qui ont perdu 25% de leur
potentiel qui sont renforcées par des
cadets qui viennent des académies
militaires ou par des réservistes donc
c'est assez hétéroclite tout ça et le
général qui vous citiez tout à l'heure 9
mai le général qui a reçu pour mission
d'en porter une victoire avant le prime
n 9 mais il a deux semaines et demie
devant lui donc c'est assez bref c'est
assez bref ce sont des opérations
terrestres longtemps par les opérations
terrestres compléter bien sûr par les
frappes dans la profondeur
les frappes vers le vivent vers kiev
vers le nieppe qui ont pour objet de
couper les ukrainiens des renforcements
qui pourrait leur arriver et les
empêcher de recevoir de nouveaux
matériels sur le front qu'ils ont
préparée depuis 2014 quand même les
ukrainiens nastasia
chapeau china le kremlin veut libérer le
dombass donc on le disait avant le 9 mai
voire avant la pâque orthodoxe d'après
ce que j'ai lu le 24 avril est ce que ça
a valeur de symbole est ce que c'est
pour effacer l'humiliation du navire
amiral moskva
absolument la vire donc le les frappes
sur le navire amiral mosca était a donc
beaucoup couvert par les médias russes
et dont beaucoup suscité aussi les
réponses donc de la société dans le sens
donc c'est est utilisé pour les buts de
plus pop rock band et ça a été une
réussite et tout ce qui est donc les
dates pour les russes soit c'est le 23
février le jour du soldat donc la
tradition soviétique donc on a vu le
début de la guerre a donc devant 4
février soit c'est le 9 mai qui est
devenu la fête quasi religieuse chez des
russes donc sous vladimir poutine avec
la victoire la guerre patriotique de la
guerre patriotique dans le deuxième
guerre mondiale et donc avec les palets
parallèle qui sont maintenant dresser a
donc avec les nazis imaginaire de
l'ukraine et les vrais nazis donc tous
les gars deuxième mondial bien sûr on
attend que il y aura en tout cas la
proclamation de victoire quelconque même
s'il n'y a qu'une victoire même s'il
n'est rien qui se passe mais bien sûr ce
serait bien de le faire avec une à tout
prix avec une grande peut-être attaque
un grand prix main mais qui va pouvoir
ensuite permettre à proclamer une
attente territoriale du l'hiver vous qui
connaissez bien le don bassin vous avez
fait plusieurs reportages pour pour
france 24 est ce que cette région peut
tomber facilement ou au contraire la
résistance ukrainienne est elle très
aguerris
en tout ce qu'on peut constater c'est
que le moral des ukrainiens est très
élevé en ce moment après les victoires
dans les régions de kiev définitive tous
les troupes russes sont partis cette
attaque réussie aussi sur le navire le
mostra qui a apparemment a fait reculer
les autres navires russes qui tiraient
depuis la mer noire de sur de nombreuses
cibles en ukraine 200 km plus loin de la
côte par peur de subir le même sort que
qu'allah moskva donc quand je parle aux
ukrainiens et ils ont une assez grande
confiance en la capacité de leurs forces
armées maintenant tu es résister à cette
attaque donc d'une basse après ce qu'ils
constatent aussi et c'est volodymyr
zelensky qu'il a souligné c'est que les
russes maintenant avance avec beaucoup
plus de prudence ils ont peut-être un
peu mieux réfléchi leur stratégie alors
que quand ils sont arrivés dans la
région de kiev et de changning il
pensait clermont pouvoir prendre la
capitale sous deux trois jours il
s'attendait pas du tout à la résistance
ukrainienne donc les russes s'en doute
sont mieux préparés que il ne l'était
avant dans le sens de la stratégie et
des tactiques qu'ils vont employer mais
le moral des russes on peut se poser est
très bas puisqu'il est clair que les
objectifs
originaux de cette invasion de l'ukraine
ne n'ont pas été atteintes ou n'est pas
du tout ne s'est pas du tout déroulée
comme ils tombent l'un des murs poutine
de près loyer tetiana hoggar kova vous
êtes d'accord avec gulliver craag ou
est-ce qu'au contraire c'est une
bataille redouté par les ukrainiens le
gouverneur de louhansk affirme que tous
les hôpitaux par exemple ont déjà été
bombardée mais il dit nous allons tenir
et nous allons vaincre
les sessions bien sûr est très tendue
mais on garde le moral et il ya une
certitude qui d'ailleurs est prêt dès le
premier jour de cette guerre que ses
dires sera la dernière guerre de
vladimir poutine ça c'est sûr et sans
doute la dernière guerre de la russie de
régime qui est en place a réussi
aujourd'hui puisque donc on a bien vu le
résultat alors l'échec massif de l'armée
russe déjà aux alentours de quilles
cherubini et soumet aussi à l'aise donc
il faut il faut le souligner est donc
déjà le changement de plan parce que au
départ on attendait des thèses sur les
béatifications démilitarisation des
lichens on a bien voulu projet de de
répéter les crèmes dans trois teintes
jours c'était c'était vraiment
surréaliste en quelque sorte et on voit
aujourd'hui le régime russe dans
l'improvisation totale parce que se
concentre sur le dos ne va pas seulement
parce que cette stratégie que quoi que
ce soit mais parce que ils peuvent pas
faire autre chose bien sûr les attaques
terroristes sur les villes telles qu'ils
vivent ou qui vivent au beau marais où
je me trouve actuellement on a reçu un
missile il ya deux jours année au
kilomètre de l'appartement où je suis
donc cessons d attaque pour effrayer
pour voilà pour détruire de temps en
temps des cibles militaires mais une
fois de plus ils frappent pas souvent
pas toujours en tout cas d'ali cibles
militaires parce que les usines qui se
trouve à deux kilomètres entre
aujourd'hui et il n'y avait jamais de
zim militaires ici c'est juste les les
fausses informations ont bien les plans
les cartes de deux je sais pas dès les
années 60 70 quand les soldats russes
lecture nobile le creuser des tranchées
a tchernobyl on faisait des blagues
qu'il disposait des cartes de 85 c'est à
dire avant l'explosion de tchernobyl et
donc que plusieurs d'entre eux n'étaient
pas au courant que c'était ce que
c'était contagieux que c'était dangereux
pour le centre pour leur santé ce qui
s'avérait vrai après parce qu'on a vu
plusieurs soldats russes a été
hospitalisé en biélorussie justement
avec cette maladie de radiation c'est
une improvisation c'est une histoire de
victoire coûte que coûte en quelque
sorte bien sûr de 9 mai est important et
donc même s'il n'y a pas de victoire ici
ils volent inventé ils vont montrer la
télévision étant donné que youtube
permet donc presque tout est bloqué ils
vont inventer une victoire quelconque
pour convaincre leur population que
poutine a gagné une fois de plus de
mille trente ans quelle est la stratégie
des ressorts va regarder à une carte
pour qu'on comprenne exactement où se
trouve ce don basse
manifestement ils veulent prendre le
dombass en tenaille c'est ça oui alors
si on voit la carte en fait voilà il ya
deux manoeuvres en cours l'une qui est
d'attaquer frontalement les réelles et
défense ukrainienne
donc si vous voulez de l'est vers
l'ouest sur
on a identifié pour l'instant trois axes
et un de ses axes peut remporter une
victoire peut permettre une percée et à
ce moment là les réserves iront sur cet
axe là ça c'est le premier de la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
enfermer c'est
s'efforce ukrainienne les coupes et des
renforts qui avait de l'ouest et ça
c'est là la manoeuvre qui part à partir
10 djoum et qui descend vers le sud mais
il faut reconnaître que hier ou
avant-hier les les ukrainiens ont lancé
une contre attaque de la région de
kharkiv qui coupait l'arrière en fait
des colonnes qui avançaient et ça c'est
la stratégie préférée des ukrainiens ces
coupés de leur logistique en fait les
forces russes et les forces russes coupe
et de logistique de carburant ou une
munition et ben s'arrête là où elles
sont ne peuvent pas aller plus loin donc
aujourd'hui les russes essayent
d'attaquer de front et de couper
derrière de façon à en fermer la fine
fleur de l'armée ukrainienne inquiets la
pape depuis 2014 qui a des positions
très préparé beaucoup d'armement de
façon à réduire cette poche parce que ça
représente une poche en fait quand on le
regarde aujourd'hui du donbass qui n'a
pas encore été conquise par les russes
crémines à j'ai entendu dire que donc ça
c'est une ville qui a été qui est tombée
aux mains des russes oui c'est une ville
au nord-est de akram à tort sq oui donc
cesser ce type dax que je signalais sur
lequel ils avancent c'est un peu si vous
voulez à l'échelle de l'ukraine vous
aviez quatre axes d' approche et puis
finalement on n'a retenu que là où il y
avait une victoire c'est à dire dans le
sud mais là ça va être pareil il va y
avoir trois axes d'approché et puis là
où il y aura la victoire eh bien on
renforcera cet endroit là pour percer et
pour morceler la défense ukrainienne et
la coupe et des renforts à l'ouest
anastasia chapeau china le dombass est
une région houillère il faut dire donc
vraiment très riche en charbon c'est un
bassin houiller et il ya donc des
régions administratif les régions
administratives de louhansk et de donner
ce qu'ils sont peuplés en grande partie
d'ailleurs de russophones cette région
est en guerre depuis 2014 ya eu
d'ailleurs 14 mille morts depuis 2014
pourquoi est ce si important pour
maintenir poutine
déjà donc le l'objectif original de
l'intervention donetsk lougansk dans le
donbass c'était 2 après surtout que
c'était devenu clair sa stratégie après
l'annexion de la cre émet donc avait
réussi c'était de
donc de
défigurer on dirait donc l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine donc de
empêcher l'ukraine de être perçue par
les partenaires occidentaux surtout en
tant qu'un pays entier est donc par
défaut d'empêcher de l'ukraine à entrer
en n'importe quelle organisation
internationale y compris le temps mais
aussi accessoirement et aux envies de
démantèlement exactement et donc là
c'était l'objectif original est douce et
je pense que c'était le seul
l'occupation de deux parties de lou
gascoun d'agnès qu deux régions étaient
suffisantes pour atteindre cet objectif
d'où je pense que le ps move
l'apaisement on des occidentaux qui ont
cru que sur ça ça va se finir parce que
vraiment les victoires mais les ternes
août sur toutes les deux régions n'a
aucun sens en tout cas les régions qui
sont déjà parmi les membres des russes
dépit 2014 ils sont aussi il y
représente déjà une force industrielle
importante et toutes les usines tout
tout ce qui était là bas et être
complètement découpé et déconsolidé sauf
les usines de hamburgers craignant
important mais juste pour dire que
justement sur ces sur 7 sur ses morceaux
lost est l objectif important au début
maintenant ç'a changé après les défaites
militaires
la presse je laissais général aussi à
trancher même pour moi c'est devenu un
peu en symbole donc harvey ira vers les
régions qui ont été déjà aperçu comme
les régions que ton compte est utilisé
en tant que prétexte pour commencer une
guerre totale donc contre l'ukraine pour
ensuite au déclarait une victoire
superficiel pour une date donnée et
gulliver vous êtes d'accord quels sont
les buts du kremlin à ce qu'il s'agit de
prendre le contrôle de luan ce qui donne
y est et marioupol ou est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'aller plus loin
pour le moment ce sont leur but affiché
officiellement et je pense que pour une
fois ils sont un peu en train de faire
ce qu ils disent qu'ils sont en train de
faire mais je suis d'accord avec
anastasia
la base le but ce n'était pas vraiment
le don de bath en 2014 ce que la russie
a fait dans le dos de basse c'était dans
le but de contrôler et l'ukraine d'avoir
une sorte de levier pour contrôler le
reste de l'ukraine le tout bas ce n'est
pas vraiment d'une grande valeur en soi
son industrie est très très très délabré
c'est plutôt un poids économique en fait
qu'en plus value économique l idée de
contrôle et d'une basse depuis 2014
c'était d'empêcher
le crâne de rejoindre le temps et c est
maintenant en 2022 cette idée de lancer
l'invasion ils ont utilisé un peu le
donbass comme un prétexte mais le but ce
n'était pas à la base juste d'avoir le
don de basse maintenant ils sont revenus
ils sont retournés sur cette idée
d'avoir le bit juste contrôler le double
bass je pense effectivement pour avoir
une victoire pour le 9 mai pour sauver
la phase pour dire que c'était ce qu'il
voulait faire depuis le début que
c'était uniquement ça de leurs
intentions mais c'est clair que ce
n'était pas uniquement ça leur intention
et puis à l'avenir s'ils remportent
cette bataille du donbass je pense qu'on
aura aucune
garantie plutôt le contraire même aucune
garantie que la russie ne se chercherait
pas à aller plus loin parce que
au long terme le but de vladimir poutine
s'est clairement de avoir une forme de
contrôle sur l'ukraine ou du moins
d'empêcher les craintes de rejoindre les
institutions occidentales ténor marco va
vous êtes d'accord avec avec gulliver
que représente le dombass pour vous les
ukrainiens il ya encore de nombreux
civils d'après ce que j'ai lu un dans
cette région
écoutez il n'est pas du tout question de
deux vastes un sale guerre puisque tout
est clair poutine a écrit un article là
n'était en juillet 2021 déjà donc tout
et pour tout était posé sur la table
donc là il était dit très clairement que
l'ukraine en tant que pays indépendant
tant qu'etat n'existe pas que c'est une
partie de la russie donc l excès une
création artificielle comme il l'a
déclaré crié par lénine donc au début du
20e siècle donc dans la tête de la
limite ultime si on s'intéresse encore à
ce qu'elles font l'ukraine en tant que
tel n'existe pas c'était déjà clair en
2014 quand il est en excès crime et donc
c'était très clair pour nous que la
grande guerre elle allait commencer ce
contact est aujourd'hui d'une base c'est
parce que il peut pas faire autre chose
c'est parce qu'il faut sauver la face et
les pauvres il faut faire semblant
qu'ils continuent après on lis très
attentivement les articles et l'article
par exemple qu'est apparue il ya
quelques semaines dans sur le site de
ria novosti c'est un site d'état donc il
parle plus de benetti fication mais il
parle déjà de la d ukraine isation de
l'écran c'est à dire que tout ce qui est
ukrainien n'existe pas donc il faut les
exterminer et donc on a très bien vu abu
tair pingers elle m'a en fait partout où
le soldat russe a mis les pieds donc
dans la région de brevard et où j'habite
pareil dans tous les villages en fête
toujours les mêmes images de de gens
tués des tortures de viols donc toute
cette cruauté encensé sans but donc ça
veut dire avec un but d'exterminer les
ukrainiens donc tous et s'est séparé et
donc le terme de génocide et n'est pas
lancée à tout hasard on sait qu'ils vont
elle m'apprend à refuser ce terme est
par contre il a soutenu par d'autres
leaders internationaux y compris
officiellement par le parlement
ukrainien a été voté que justement que
l'agression russe on a qualifié
aujourd'hui de génocide et ce n'est pas
pour rien mais justement parce que
regarder ce qui se passe à mariupol les
gens qui passent qui qui arrive qui
arrive à quitter la ville et qui sont
forcés à quitter la ville vers la
direction de russie et passe on a déjà
plusieurs témoignages par les camps de
filtration écouter seulement le langage
de filtration c'est à dire peu qu'il ya
des interrogatoires avec les civils on
leur pose des questions et selon leur
sympathie pour lui qui conte les filtres
c'est à dire que ce qui ne passe pas ce
processus de filtration on ignore le
sort on ne sait pas ce qu'ils arrivent
donc l'ampleur des erreurs qui arrive
aux ukrainiens en russie ville surtout
parce que les civils souffrent beaucoup
plus que militaires craignent en ce
moment il est énorme elle est
énormissime donc le but de poutine bien
sûr ce n'est pas du tout encore un
village aura encore une ville à une
basse mais bien sûr on se prépare à ce
combat et on doit faire tout le possible
je veux dire l'ukraine mais aussi nos
partenaires occidentaux pour empêcher
justement voilà cette agression ruche
qui a un sens et qu'ils emportent rien
ni à rue signal on va revenir justement
sur ce que vont ce que va faire l'otan
et les états unis mais avant avant cela
2000 trinquent encore et encore une
question de stratégie sur le front de la
mer noire dans le sud à odessa il ya peu
de mouvement est-ce que c'est lié à ces
pertes encore une fois de ce navire
amiral est ce qu'il a vraiment porté
préjudice aux forces russes n'ont alors
le peu de mouvements de côté 2 dès ça
c'est grâce à la défense de nicolaï qui
a arrêté en fait l'offensive qui
venaient de l'est
par cap après carson la saisie de
nicolay n'a pas été possible est donc le
seul moyen de prendre dès sa part la
terre pourrait éventuellement la
transnistrie mais personne n'en parle
donc la transnistrie doit pas être prête
à le prendre je pense est donc qu'est ce
qui s'est passé eu un blocus maritime
qui a été mis en place donc le port
d'odessa devient
inutilisable à cause du blocus et donc
la sphère du moskva qui a été coulé en
fait c'est ce blocus qui a subi cette
perte
d'où le recul des bateaux mais il ya
toujours un blocus au large de d'odessa
en revanche je pense que la russie a
abandonné l'idée de saisir au dessin
parce qu'elle ne peut pas le saisir par
la terre tout bêtement donc vous êtes
d'accord un gulliver la russie aurait
abandonné pour l'instant tout cas l'idée
de saisir au dessin
je ne sais pas exactement parce que ils
pompent bardasser intensément ces
derniers jours microlife donc je ne suis
pas sûr s'ils ont vraiment abandonné
l'idée de prendre mikolaj g l'idée de
prendre nicolaï c'est bien sûr après
d'ouvrir la porte vers une attaque sur
le dessin je voulais souligner aussi
autre chose c'est que si au début de
l'invasion les russes ont avancé assez
rapidement et en prix du territoire dans
le sud de l'ukraine dans le donbass ils
ont pris très peu de territoire ils ont
même pas pu prendre même jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à venir qu'à et marine kaki
sont dépensés en réalité des villes
satellites de donetsk qui sont restés
aux mains des iraniens depuis 2014 ils
les ont bombardés très intensément mais
il n'arrive pas donc ça en dit long sur
la préparation des ukrainiens dans cette
région pour faire face aux attaques
russes et joe biden était en réunion
virtu elle est aujourd'hui une réunion
consacrée à l'offensive russe bien sûr
en ukraine avec ses principaux alliés
dont emmanuel macron la france le
président américain il ya évoqué le
soutien continu à l'ukraine et les
efforts visant à s'assurer que la russie
allait rendre des comptes on va écouter
d'abord le ministre de la défense russe
lui accuse l'occident de faire durer le
conflit
les états unis et les états occidentaux
qu'ils contrôlent font tout pour faire
durer au maximum l'opération militaire
spéciale
les livraisons croissante d'armées
étrangères démontre clairement leurs
intentions celle que le régime de kiev
se battent jusqu'au dernier des
ukrainiens
anastasia chapeau ch qui n'a alors
évidemment il inverse c'est à dire que
c'est à cause de cette aide occidentale
que finalement les ukrainiens
et bien peu peuvent se défendre en fait
qu'il devrait en fait pourquoi dit il ça
le mythe de la défense russe mais du
coup tout ce qui est la communication du
ministre de la défense sous n'importe
quel autre ministre le président de la
russie c'est toujours ciblé sur le
peuple est sûr de la réussite est là il
faut il faut comprendre que la cette
population il a vraiment subi à un
torrent de la propagande qui est un
discours très structurée sur les raisons
de la guerre dans ce discours c'est
l'occident qui a commencé la guerre
c'est contre l'occident que la guerre
est menée par la russie et l'ukraine
n'est même presque pas une partie c'est
presque un proxy de l'occident et cédera
donc et l'ukraine n'est pas une nation
exactement comme tatiana regard que va
expliquer c'est ce n'est pas et ce n'est
pas en étant soi et ne nomme jamais le
président ukrainien est évoquée en vain
que les deux ne pas perçu comme tel et
ce discours et l'ailé leïla c'est encore
la faute de l'occident ce qui précise
l'aide supplémentaire
peut-être que vous savez ça tetyana au
garrot gare kova pardon l'aide
américaine est ce qu'elle arrive en
ukraine donc il ya 800 milliards de
dollars de dette supplémentaire depuis
la semaine dernière prévus avec
notamment des formations également de
formateurs ukrainien envoyés sur le
terrain et on parle de d'obusiers de
drones est ce qu'elle arrive
effectivement en ukraine
et
rapproche les deux sources donc mais on
sent bien toujours le flouze la guerre
et qui hélas a fait et dont on sait
qu'il y ait des résultats qui est des
réseaux sur le front qui est sans doute
aussi qu'ils sont aussi aidé par parler
de militaires qui arrive de l'occident
mais une fois de plus même au niveau
officiel c'est très peu communiqué donc
c'est justement cette dernière aide
qu'on avait vu justement les caisses qui
était dedans en fait parce qu'avant
c'était juste des déclarations un peu
floue puisque le but le but était très
clair ne pas irriter la russie ne pas
faire semblant que l'occident ont le
parfum des partenaires occident
occidentaux et les craintes sont dedans
dans le jeu pour pas et pour faut pas
qu'il y ait une escalade ça c'était
important aujourd'hui on voit qui a
déplu en plus de courage de la part de
nos partenaires occidentaux qui n'ont
plus peur vos rêves vraiment vous dire
ce qui est vrai mais ça prend bien sûr
un certain temps que ça arrive jusqu'à
champ de bataille est donc pour on voit
des résultats mais on espère que ne va
pas tarder 800 millions de dollars bien
sûr un demi-train quand est ce qu'elle
arrive effectivement sur place ses
dettes cette aide les pays bas annoncent
même envoyé des armes lourdes en ukraine
ça pourrait changer la donne oui alors
d'abord il faut se souvenir que l'aide
elle date de 2014 quand même depuis les
années 2014 l'aide est arrivée sous
forme de formation sous forme
d'équipements et si l'armée ukrainienne
est très courageuse reconnaissons-le
aujourd'hui c'est aussi parce qu'elle a
été formé et équipé faut pas l'oublier
ensuite depuis la guerre l'armement
arrive maintenant
disons que quand on livre de l'armement
c'est pas on ne le dis pas pour ne pas
irriter le russe sait simplement que ça
fait partie des sujets qu'on n'aborde
pas on livre de l'armement sans révéler
tout l'armement avec toutes les
techniques qu'on a derrière quand on
parle justement de ce seuil armes
lourdes ou paco belligérance ou pas
comment parler d'armements offensifs
défensifs
j'ai jamais compris la différence -
militaire entre l'armement offensifs et
défensifs et maintenant lourd pas lourd
évidemment des chars et des obligés
c'est forcément l'eau mais il faut pas
oublier tout le reste de l'aide c'est à
dire aujourd'hui les images
satellitaires les renseignements donnés
on parlait des sept généraux russes qui
ont été tuées comment ont-ils été tués
parce que leur pc ont été repérés grâce
au système satellitaire les coordonnées
donné à la retirer aux ukrainiens qui
ont utilisé l'artillerie pour taper sur
les pc et tuer les généraux donc si vous
voulez il ya aujourd'hui en permanence
des choses qui sont pas plus importantes
parce que tout est important mais les
obusiers c'est important bien sûr mais à
mon avis les images satellitaires et le
renseignement c'est au moins aussi
important et il est probable que le
bateau qui a été coulé le moskva c'est
probablement parce qu'on avait repéré
qui faisait des ronds dans l'eau
toujours les mêmes depuis plusieurs
jours et ça on l'a vu par des satellites
et les satellites ont transmis ça et
ensuite les ukrainiens ont monté une
manoeuvre remarquable avec un drone et
de tirs de missiles qui en coule tel
bateau donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que l'aide il ya ce qui est sûr les
caméras il ya ce qu'on parle dans les
médias et puis à l'arrêt lité sur le
terrain avec probablement des
infiltrations sur le terrain pour aider
les ukrainiens directement évidemment
qu'on n'en parle pas mais hélas qui
demandent plus d'être encore toujours
plus dead non mais effectivement on du
coup il ya aussi l'armement lourd qui
maintenant on a vu les annonces
américaines mais ce que je dis
c'est que le surprise c'est salle
leclerc et le fait que les écrits n'y en
a obtenu une larme qui a permis de
frapper la navire effectivement la
manière efficace quand on frappait
ensuite face à hull sont son résultat
c'est aussi c'est à dire ce que healy a
décrit deux présents à rien qu'ils ont
été entendus et je voudrais juste
ajouter saah sah tout ce qu'il a dit sur
l'aide sur le long terme d'intro 2014 et
aujourd'hui ce qui était fait c'était
une année c'était une véritable réforme
de la défense anglaise y compris les
ressources de défense du système d'achat
qui a vraiment était beaucoup beaucoup
surveillé par le ministère de la défense
surtout américains et
britanniques qui ont beaucoup donc
sponsorisés aussi ce système et surtout
ceux qui aujourd'hui marc larre et les
différences remarquables entre l'armée
ukrainienne et l'armée russe c'est
l'alignement avec les standards de
l'otan qui est supposé aussi
l'alignement sur les standards rh
aujourd'hui les 15 meilleurs c'est à
dire que même aujourd'hui donc les
petits l'épaissir groupe de soldats
ukrainien qui se retrouve dans les
poches isolées etc ils peuvent et sont
complètement capable de mener leurs
propres de mener leur prendre leurs
propres décisions mener leurs opérations
et ils peuvent pas demander à chaque
seconde au centre de quoi faire parce
que ils ont acquis cette autonomie qui
est la culture du soldat qui est
complètement différente du culture de
soldats soviétiques qui aujourd'hui
toujours hérité par les russes qui
attend eu à chaque instant le que le
commandement est si il n'y a pas de
commandement mais ils peuvent corps et
d'un mba en essence que il n'ya pas
cette culture de l'autonomie culture des
ressources humaines qui est propre à
beaucoup d'armes est de l'otan sur tout
les armées etc les deux le temps est uni
et la france donc ils sont beaucoup plus
performants qu auparavant et c'est parmi
elles craignaient aujourd'hui on a un
mari poehl a donc c'est long les ukraine
les données donc et les ukrainiens
russes et l'est un soldat ukrainien pour
six soldats russes main soldats
ukrainien pour six soldats russes qui
selon les occasions se sont toujours là
mais après en tout cas il n'est pas
beaucoup hacker qui restent à
l'intérieur mais donc mm justement est
ça tient toujours sa salle tient
toujours c'est la décentralisation du
combat qui est à clé être capable de
décider et de mener son combat une fois
qu'on sait dans quelles zones que l'on a
quel effet on a à peu devenir alors
qu'effectivement l'armée russe est
extrêmement centralisé et déroule comme
un rouleau compresseur ses moyens et
gulliver ask est tout de même un
problème de l'acheminement de cette
nouvelle aide militaire vers le donbass
forcément puisque il ya beaucoup qu'il
de kilomètres à couvrir avec les russes
sont bien déterminés à essayer de
détruire ses armes et c'est pour cela
que cela se fait dans le plus grand
secret je pense qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
de contradictions en réalité entre
volodymyr zelensky pour qui c'est son
devoir de demander toujours plus le soir
mais je pense que les ukrainiens sont
effectivement inquiet qu'il n'y en a pas
assez et le fait qu' on ne sait pas
exactement qu'est ce qui est livrée et
quant à hugh puisque évidemment il faut
faire tout ce qui est possible pour
empêcher les risques de savoir où ces
armements se trouver et de tirer sur les
convois tetyana rogard kova est ce que
les ukrainiens peuvent perdre cette
bataille du dombass
écouté personne ne le sait en fait parce
que la guerre n'est jamais finie
teintées n'est pas finie donc on va voir
mais je crois que il y a toutes les
chances du côté ukrainien puisque tout
d'abord il ya ce côté motivation dont on
a déjà évoqué les soldats et craignant
se bat pour la terre qui appartient à
cette sopi à cet état donc c'est très
clair la motivation c'est un combat
existentiel puisque les les intentions
de la russie sont très connus sont sur
la table donc pour eux quand j'ai des
amis les près d'un an que tel n'existe
pas donc les motivations d'un soldat
russe c'est autre chose des autres déjà
vous les pertes selon les sources
officielles ukrainiens se vend mieux
soldats russes qui ont déjà perdu leur
vie dans dans cette bataille donc on
voit on reçoit toujours l'information
sur la démotivation des soldats russes
dont côté motivation c'est plutôt
soldats ukrainien en plus il ya de
l'aide déjà évoqué qui vient de nos
partenaires occidentaux et par contre la
russie qui commence et qui va encore
plus souffrir avec le poids des
sanctions et donc pour renommer
l'arsenal militaire elles vont avoir des
problèmes donc je dirais que tout ça
c'est des facteurs là il met plutôt les
chances de côté des l'ukraine ce qu'on
est bien sûr qu'on craignait on espère
et on souhaite de tout notre coeur
général train quand est ce qu
effectivement les ukrainiens peuvent
gagner au donbass oui alors je rajoute à
ce qui vient d'être évoquée qui parle d
des valeurs morales en fait et des
soldats ukrainiens par rapport aux
soldats russes à la préparation depuis
2014 c'était et tout à l'heure
votre correspondant à kef citer que
l'avancé n'avait pas été très forte du
donbass forcément c'est là car mais
craignent c'est enterrer s'est préparé
depuis huit ans et l'avancée évidemment
elle est venue de la crimée et non pas
du donbass donc là le les armées russes
vont se trouver face à des dépositions
extrêmement bien préparées depuis huit
ans ça veut dire quoi bien préparer ça
veut dire enterré bétonné avec des plans
de feu avec des positions de rechange
avec des capacités de renforts sur
pourquoi tu auras une conque une attaque
par exemple capacité de monter une
contre attaque contre des positions
russes les l'armée ukrainienne connaît
par coeur tout cette occasion là et donc
elle l'a préparé une chanson comme rossi
non parce que les russes n'étaient pas
là les ukrainiens ils sont là depuis
huit ans
donc ils ont préparé ils connaissent
tous par coeur les russes il était de
l'autre côté ils pouvaient regarder avec
des images satellites mais c'est pas la
même chose que quand vous avez repérer
toutes les choses au sol donc je pense
que en plus des valeurs morales il ya
cette préparation du terrain et cette
préparation donc combat pour le côté
ukrainien alors que du côté russe il ya
bien sûr la masse énorme en particulier
de la retirer
anastasia chapeau qui n'a vous êtes
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit
par le général train quand est ce que
finalement si les ukrainiens gagne au
donbass est ce que vladimir poutine sera
tenté d'utiliser l'armé nucléaire je
pense que rien n'empêche la demi-heure
petit utilise l arme de destruction
massive soit ce se soit l'armé chimique
ou nucléaire
c'est parce que malheureusement ce qu'on
ne remarque dans cette guerre comme on a
déjà vu dans les guerres de la russie en
tchétchénie pendant les deux guerres de
tchétchénie aussi en syrie ce que n'est
pas de limite donc de violence après si
donc il gagne pas cette bataille ça veut
pas dire que la guerre soit fini non
c'est ça le problème c'est que le 8 ans
ce que le son est qu'ils ont montré aux
ukrainiens ce que les russes il est
toujours là elle joue toujours un long
terme aide quand tout le monde a pensé
aux espérer que ça peut se finir le
conflit va devenir gelé et c'est que la
russie elle juste entendu se préparait
et les revenus et c'est pour ça que sur
odessa aujourd'hui on a dit aussi qu'il
sombre coulé à cause de ces difficultés
là mais demain échanger se reforme donne
deux ans dans 85 ans ils peuvent revenir
n'importe quel moment n'importe quel
endroit c'est ça le problème qui est là
avec la russie dont 7 cette victoire là
aujourd'hui elle est très importante
pour les ukrainiens surtout parce que
c'est leur hui qui se joue mais à la fin
ça pas dire que ça va être serait ce la
fin du iv à ce qu effectivement
meilleure poutine pourrait être tenté
par le nucléaire par l'armé nucléaire
s'il perd au donbass
en tout cas c'est quelque chose que les
gens puissent y à kiev évoqua
sérieusement comme une crainte réelle
par ou d'armes nucléaires tactiques des
petites armes nucléaires si vous voulez
mais qui a évidemment provoqué des
dégâts extraordinaires et je pense que
sergueï lavrorv aujourd'hui a dit que
non non non il n'aurait pas cette
possibilité mais oui il a dit ça il est
là dilmi la défense lui des affaires
étrangères russe a je n'ai pas utilisé
le nucléaire mais ce qu'il faut le
croire
cela cela ne rassure pas beaucoup les
ukrainiens je pense que ce qui leur
assure peut-être un petit peu plus c'est
énorme table que vladimir poutine
utilisent chaque fois qu'il rencontre un
autre dirigeant étranger ou bien même
ses propres ministres si cet homme-là a
tellement peur du coup vite il faut
croire qu'il aurait peut-être à ses
parents qu'à deux attaques elle est
aléatoire s'ils utilisent l arme
nucléaire et que peut-être ce n'est pas
l'homme qui a vraiment le courage ou
l'envi de prendre de tels risques cette
table peut-être dit quelque chose sur le
caractère de vladimir poutine qu'on peut
ou on peut trouver un petit peu de
rassurance si on veut chercher de la
réassurance quelque part c'est yao au
regard kova vous êtes d'accord avec avec
gulliver
s qui rien tenté d'utiliser leurs armes
nucléaires notamment s'il perd dans le
donbass
je crois que la question à poser serait
de guillet de se demander qu'est ce que
nous doit faire ce que nous on peut
faire pour empêcher cette pensée même
avait dit mi-août est ce que les états
nucléaires parce que le crâne n'est pas
un état nucléaire est ce qu'on peut
faire pour le dissuader nous pas nous
penser à ça je pense que les risques
existent bien sûr malheureusement mais
les risques sont moins grande qu'au
départ de ce conflit puisque poutine a
déjà démontré qu'il est faible donc le
leader faible et donc pour donner un
ordre qui peut donner un autre comme ça
mais après pour exécuter l'ordre il faut
pas que poutine il faut quelqu'un
d'autre après il faut qu'il y ait des
garanties pour eux donc après donc et
avec un leader faible il a beaucoup
moins de deux fois en fait de
possibilité de le faire et donc nous on
évoque ouvre nous on pense que les
chances qu'ils utilisent vraiment que la
clause d'utiliser leur nucléaires sont
inférieurs aujourd'hui qu'il ya un mois
et demi gérard fra quand vous êtes
d'accord oui c'est très mois mois
susceptible utilisé aujourd'hui qu'il ya
un mois je ne crois absolument pas à
cette menace nucléaire pour une raison
simple le nucléaire tactique ça sert à
quoi quels objectifs on vient de parler
de l'armée ukrainienne qui est
décentralisée quels objectifs vous
voulez vous taper avec une arme
nucléaire lorsque vous avez des forces
qui sont éparpillés sur le terrain
faut qu'il ya un objectif est que ça
serve à calais en visée non mais t'es
regagné non mais gagner gagner avec les
forces qu'il a il espère le faire mais
si c'est utiliser leur savoir et dire
qu'il a perdu ça voudrait dire qu'il a
perdu je rappelle qu'elle est russe le
roadie la menace nucléaire c'est en cas
de menace existentielle sur la russie
c'est à dire que si la russie est
attaqué s'il ya un problème en russie à
l'extérieur de la russie
c'est une preuve de faiblesse
votre
interlocutrice qui était à en ukraine le
dit bien c'est une preuve de faiblesse
et on ne veut pas montrer une faiblesse
deux ans ensuite pour revenir sur votre
point sur le travail dans la durée
souvenons nous simplement que depuis
cette semaine nous observons noonan
analysons nous enregistrons tout ce qui
se passe et ça ça nous permet de voir
toutes les failles de l'armée russe et
donc sur le longtemps nombreuses si je
comprends vermand elles sont nombreuses
ces failles exactement et donc ça tout
le temps lent grange et ça lui permet de
mieux se préparer s'il y avait à
affronter directement la russie à ce qui
aura des sanctions supplémentaires elles
sont en discussion vous pensez que c'est
quelque chose d'important aujourd'hui
avec qui m'ont donc là les etats-unis
ont dit qu il y a encore une longue
liste des sanctions possibles va
effectivement un niveau de train de
sanctions qui devraient arriver
exactement pas l'embargo donc sur le gaz
et du pétrole russes sont parmi des
sections indiscuté mais le plus
difficile bien sûr pour les etats unis
c'est facile à me poser ces sanctions
c'est un pays qui se autres provisions
dans le pétrole et du gaz pour les
partenaires européens c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué et pour l'instant on n'a
pas vu cette personne là bien sûr ce
genre de sanction serait
accompli deux objectifs d'abord il
dray à succès vraiment le budget russe
et d'un de manière beaucoup plus
importante que aujourd'hui y avait un
embargo sur le gaz et du pétrole le gaz
ou du pétrole et ensuite deuxièmement ça
pousserait la russie dans les membres de
la chine complètement en faisant de la
russie en annexe donc de la chine et
peut-être axé sur mont de lans date un
ex de ressources mais et ça ce serait
complètement pas comparable déjà avec
les partenaires occidentaux parce que
déjà les chinoises dicteront les prix à
la russie et par le marché et
deuxièmement parce que les chinois
aujourd'hui déjà achète du bio prennent
du pétrole russe aux gratuitement dans
les grandes quantités selon les vieux
contrats pour rembourser les dettes
chinois aux russes qu'ils ont donnée
depuis 2014 tetiana hoggar kova vous
pensez que ça serait bien qu'ils aient à
nouveau train de sanctions encore
aujourd'hui c'est efficace
oui bien sûr à long terme en cause
conclut sur une civière qui arrangerait
les 15 serait la défaite militaire de la
russie qui serait possible uniquement
avec la destruction de l'équivalent
d'une machine de guerre qui existent
donc les sanctions doivent être adéquat
pour pas que cette guerre se prolonge
des mois et des années on paie tous les
jours le cours du mans donc il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui meurt en ukraine
en grand nombre en fait donc même dans
les minutes de la minute où je vous
parle donc bien sûr notre intérêt que ça
se termine au plus vite possible et bien
sûr les sanctions donc on n'y a pas
d'argent à faire la guerre la guerre ça
coûterait cher donc qu'il n'ya pas
d'argent à faire la guerre la guerre va
s'arrêter donc autant de continuer ces
deux de voix nécessaires les sanctions
toujours plus forte avec chaque jour de
l'agression de plus et bien sûr
l'armement de leucate il est beaucoup
plus d'armes pour qu'on puisse justement
repousser l'armée russe vers leurs
frontières tout simplement merci
beaucoup tetyana hoggar kova d'avant est
avec no mercy gulliver également york
qui était avec mobile vers crack qui est
avec nous à kiev merci beaucoup général
dominique traquant merci anastasija
chapeaux chics qui n'a je vais y arriver
merci à vous et merci à vous tous nous a
reçus et reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]